awesome so welcome everyone to another
episode of d4p
data for the people and this is our co
vid 19 series and so our goal is to
provide the science for all straight
from the source and today I'm going to
be presenting a paper that talks about
the human antibody responses to costars
close to before you get started I do
want to take a moment of silence in lieu
of George Floyd who lost his life his
life unfortunately to cop brutality as a
black scientist it would behoove me not
to take the time out to recognize that
this is still happening and it's really
hard a lot of times for us as minorities
to separate ourselves from our
professions and so I just want us to
take about 10 seconds just to remember
awesome thank you guys there's so much
more I would like to say about this but
I think we'll go straight into the signs
um so once again for those who don't
know I am always make a you know big
stink about where I'm from so I'm
actually from the United States Virgin
Islands or US territory more
specifically I'm from the large island
of st. Croix we're actually only 84
square miles about 60,000 in population
and once again I'm just gonna showcase
one of our beautiful beaches and the
weather today as you can see I'm in my
backyard but I would much rather it be a
beach background here's my little family
my husband is on vacation so he's
actually watching our son and this is
him helping me with my presentation
which actually almost went haywire this
morning when he spilled coffee on my
laptop but that's a story for another
day
all as well so keep it moving all right
so a little bit about the publications
that scientists put out so publications
is basically a central source where we
can communicate our research findings
and it happens in a variety of ways the
problem is a lot of these reports are
topic specific and very jargon specific
and so it's really hard for a lot of
people outside of the field to kind of
depict exactly what the conversation is
on or what the data is showing and so
the paper presented today is actually
one from a peer-reviewed article and so
this article is nature of medicine and
what peer-reviewed mean is that is
evaluated by other scientists in the
field and it's seen as a report that is
fleshed out properly all the datasets
look fine and then it's published um so
we talked about through all the d4p
presentations about the styles of
scientific reasoning on this paper looks
into experimental evaluation and so
that's used
investigations to establish different
patterns to look for differences or to
develop hypothetical model so for
example in this paper we're looking at
the timing of antibody responses in
patient samples so here's a screen shot
of the paper so like I mentioned it's
from nature medicine and this paper is
entitled antibody responses to stars
close to which is the virus that stars
that gives you the disease kovat 19 in
patients now what's really fascinating
about this paper is that they're not
just one nor ten they're actually about
50 authors on this paper just
highlighting again the collaborative
effort that it takes for scientists to
put together datasets that can be
produced in a platform what can be used
to initiate different public health
initiatives now throughout my
presentation I'm going to talk about a
number of key terms so one of those
terms I'm gonna
antibodies and antigen I'm also going to
talk about sera conversion as well as
aggregate and individual data points and
so just a brief background on how their
body elicits our immune response to SARS
close to so the virus SARS close to as
seen here it's an RNA virus which you
see in the center and it's protected by
a lipid bilayer within that lipid
bilayer there are a number of different
proteins but they're also these surface
proteins in this case it's spike protein
that is not only elicit or immune
response to the virus but it's also
necessary for binding to the receptor on
your cell in order for entry and
replication to occur
now once the virus binds the cell and
enters and replicate it can cause an
immune response so not only is an immune
response initiated towards the surface
proteins but remembers funds can be made
from the proteins that protect the RNA
like nuclear proteins or other proteins
within the matrix of the virus now our
immune system is very complex and I've
known Lee gonna talk about one part of
the immune system which is adaptive
immunity but there's also in it
which is like the first line of defense
it's nonspecific it just targets and
tries to eliminate anything that's worn
inside of the body
unlike in it immunity adaptive immunity
recognize specific antigens so what
occurs we have a virus which is a
pathogen so in this case we have SARS
close to SARS co2 enters ourselves
replicates our body recognizes it at
some as something foreign and so that
foreign antigen triggers an immune
response within your body and so that
immune response can go on to do several
things and so the immune response
basically recognizes this pathogen and
recognizes certain parts of the pathogen
which we call antigens and so you can
either listen to human response where
different cells have certain receptors
on their to bring about many other
immune cells to combat infection or we
can make these and or we can make these
specialized molecules called antibodies
that is used to protect us in the future
now these antibodies are fairly specific
so they recognize specific parts of the
antigen where they can bind and
eliminate infection and so the paper
that I'm going to talk about today focus
is on this part of the immune response
which is a production of antibodies
that's specific to SARS close to so how
does the antibody antigen work and so
within adaptive immunity you have a
number of different antibodies that are
produced by the human body there are
actually five different types of
antibodies you have i GG IgM IgG IgM IgE
and IgA for our purposes today I'm only
gonna focus on two antibodies that I'm
going to talk about in the next slide
but these antibodies our record
recognizes different parts of the virus
so here stars co2 after it enters the
cell and so these antibodies that are
produced can then bind specific parts of
the virus and in this case despite
protein and work to either recruit of
the immune cells to get rid of infection
or neutralize the virus so that it
doesn't infect your cells so what are
these two major antibodies that seems to
be implicated in SARS close to infection
so we have IgM the IgM is one of the
first antibodies to come into play you
your body encounters a foreign antigen
or foreign particle it recognizes that
it does not belong there
and so IgM actually exists off of the
cells so if it's not on a cell as a
receptor it exists alone as a pentamer
so a pentamer is just meaning five
molecules linked together and once these
molecules enter the bloodstream it sends
messages to the rest of the immune
system to produce other antibodies and
in this case it usually produces helps
to produce IgG antibodies now i Gigi
antibodies are the most abundant in
antibodies where you can detect in
humans blood samples within the serum
and so IgG exists as a monomer meaning
one molecule all right so our first poll
which antibody type is thought to
provoke long-term immunity in humans
sokovia 19 a GM IgG IgE DD or IgE give
you a couple seconds to answer
well five more seconds awesome so let's
see what you thought
all right so 48 percent thought it was
AI GG coming into a close second is IgM
what about 36% of the vote so the
majority actually went and so it's
actually thought that IgG is the
antibody that is thought to provide
immunity for an X infection to that same
virus alright so one of those key terms
I'm going to talk about right now which
is sera conversion what is there a
conversion so sorry conversion is that
time point where you go from being
undetectable for a specific antibody to
being able to detect that antibody
within that patient's blood sample and
so here on this graph we have on the
y-axis we have the time course of
infection and then on the Left we have
the amount present so usually it takes
some time from being infected for our
bodies to sera convert to producing a
certain amount of item bodies so you can
say at this time point this patient sir
converted IgM antibodies and at this
time point their sir converted IgG
antibodies and I'll talk a lot more
about syrup conversion in the
presentation now another thing that this
study points out is the different types
of datasets that we have and so we can
either look at data sets as aggregate
data and so this involves many different
data points which can show trends and
comparisons using statistical analyses
but it doesn't look at the individual
and so that's where individual data
comes into play and so sometimes when
we're looking at I could get data sets
they might be individual
that may respond slightly differently
and so a lot of times scientists Zone
into the individual to try to figure out
how we can develop personalized
approaches to that person's response I'm
so what's the question like what did
this paper go into describe and try to
answer and so there's a lot of there's
not much information on there and
exactly how our antibodies respond to
Cove in 1905 a immune system response to
Cove in nineteen and so this is a graph
I've also used this the last time when I
was describing the test that we used to
develop antibodies and so there's still
some questions that we're trying to
understand so one of the first goals
that authors look into is when do we see
Sarah conversion and how long does it
last so when can we see a when can we
detect IgM antibodies in a patient
sample when can we detect IgG antibodies
in a patient sample how long does the
presence of IgM occurs and also how long
does I G G stay after someone is
infected with kovat 19 but the authors
also wanted to look at something else so
we also try to the authors also try to
decide if antibody testing can
complement viral testing and so I
briefly mentioned it but in the
beginning you can actually use a
specific test called rt-pcr and I won't
describe it now but if you want you can
go back to France d4p presentation where
she goes into detail as to how
scientists can take the genetic
information change it into a way that we
can detect it in a patient and so we use
our G PCR to detect if there are any
viral samples or viral particles within
that patient who may be currently
infected another test that we use is
antibody testing such as Eliza which
I've mentioned in the first d4p talk so
feel free to also check that out where
we look at the presence or absence of
either of these antibodies so does
someone have a GM antibodies do they
have IgG antibodies have they recovered
from inside
or two currently infected with SARS
close to so for this study I'm gonna
describe the patient design or how they
were able to design the study with the
patient that they had so this is study
incorporated 285 patients from Chongqing
China and there were three hospitals
that they were able to get patients from
out of these 285 patients 250 of them
had some type of epidemiological history
so what that means is that these
patients either were residents of Wuhan
recently have been to Han or have come
into close contact with a resident of
Wuhan or someone who have confirmed coal
bed 19 out of those 285 patients 262 of
them had clear symptom onset so what
that means is that these patients knew
exactly when their symptoms began so
they were hospitalized the doctor acts
them the history and they could have
told the doctor I experienced fatigue or
headache or high fever at a certain day
and out of that 285 patient data set we
have 70 of them where the scientists
were able to gather multiple serum
samples to look at the sera conversion
of the one that I'm going to talk about
later in the presentation so one of the
first questions that the scientists
asked are when our antibodies produced
after someone's infected with SARS co2
and so scientists are looking at the
presence of these antibodies that
they're able to detect
after these patients started having
symptoms so what we're looking at is
when patients are producing IgM
antibodies and when they're producing
IgG antibodies and how long after their
symptoms are these antibodies being
produced so to answer this question they
use to 262 patients of these patients
they had 363 serum samples and so serum
is just part of the blood that are we
can detect the antibodies and so they
have 363 because they have multiple
samples from certain patients that I
described before now from
these samples they use a type of Eliza
to detect the presence of the IgG or IgM
antibodies and so what do they see so
here in this graph I want to highlight a
couple things
select Zone in on the x-axis and so here
we see the days after the patients
started having symptoms so we have data
set from about two to four days post
having symptoms to about 23 days after
they started having symptoms on the
y-axis what we're looking at is a
positive rate so how many of these
patients are we able to see that detect
that we can detect either IgM IgG or
both of these antibodies so we're not
looking at the amount of antibodies but
just if they can detect it or they can't
can't cannot detect it and so what we're
seeing at about 20 days after patients
have symptoms you have about 94% of them
where you can detect the IgG IgM
antibodies and at about 17 days post
symptoms onset a hundred percent of the
patient samples they were able to detect
IgG antibodies but what this chart
doesn't show us is the amount of
antibodies present within these patients
that have contracted coded 19 and so
next scientists wanted to see what the
levels were of these antibodies within
these patients so for this data set we
are using 262 patients and so I'm gonna
show you the first data set that day
show where on the bottom of the x-axis n
is the number of patients that they are
assessing under each time point above
the end number you have the days after
symptoms onset so here we have within
the first week within the second week so
on and so forth under y-axis we're
looking at the levels of antibodies and
just a reminder that this is a log scale
so it's exponentially more as you go up
the scale and so the authors also do
statistical analysis to show a number of
things it's also on a point out that
this is an example of aggregate data
that includes individual
points so all of these dots are the
individual patients but we're using
statistics to look at the median or the
mean of all of the data points together
so we can look at the aggregate data or
the data on a whole and so this box
indicates the first and third percentile
of patients the bar within the middle of
the box look at the average of all of
those patients together and then we have
the whiskers so anything outside of the
whiskers we can say that these patients
who are outliers within that sample set
so this is i GG that we're looking at
and what you can see if we're looking at
the averages of all of the data is that
you see a continuous increase in the
levels of IgG antibodies up to about
past three weeks post symptoms onset so
the authors also looked at the amount of
IgM antibodies levels in the patient and
so what you see here is on the bottom we
have the number of patients that they're
looking at and the days after they
started having symptoms and so here you
can see as well when we're looking at
IgG the averages of this aggregate data
you see a trend of an increase of IgM
antibodies in terms of the levels that
we're seeing and after three weeks you
start to see a slight decline of that
levels once again there are some
individual data points that are outliers
but we in order to get a picture of the
population on a whole we have to use
this aggregate aggregate data set to
look at the averages so we can infer how
the population reacts to a certain
stimulus so for all this slide is
showing that we're seeing a slight
decrease in IgM after three weeks so
what does this change what we know it's
in the first graph that I've been
presenting I'm showing that initially
you're seeing IgM antibodies being
detected and then you're seeing IgG
antibodies detected with IgM decreasing
as IgG increases now this changes the
graph a little so we're starting to see
is that it seems that antibodies are
produced around the same time and after
about three weeks or so you're seeing a
slight decrease in antibodies left and
about
levels for IgM what you're seeing a
continuous increase in IgG and the
authors also point out that some of the
patient samples started to remain steady
or plateaued throughout the time point
now there's a lot of talk about whether
or not a patient has a more severe case
of probit 19 if they produce more
antibodies than someone who has a less
severe case of Ovid 19 or are
asymptomatic to infection and so what
the authors do to combat this question
is that they look at a subset of
patients who they classified as severe
so severe would be someone who's been
admitted into the ICU and so out of the
patient cohort they had about 20 that
they classified as having severe so the
orange dots are severe cases the green
are non severe cases and you're also
looking at the time after the patient
started having symptoms so here in this
portion of the graph we're looking at
the first week after patients started to
have symptoms and here we're looking at
the second week after they started to
have symptoms now this data set shows
we're gonna Zone in on the median of
this entire patient data set and we're
seeing that there seems to be a trend of
people who have severe cases of koban
have higher levels of IgG antibodies
being produced unlike those who have non
severe cases but also wanna point out if
you were to Zone in on the individual
data that we do have some patients who
are also producing large amounts of
antibodies and even though they don't
have severe symptoms they looked at the
same thing at two Outpost two weeks of
symptoms onset and used to see a slight
increase of antibodies produced in
comparison to those who have non severe
the only significant difference that
they show is within that first week with
IgG and so what the p-values indicate is
how much that this phenomenon is
occurring by chance and scientists pick
a number which is P equals 0.05 and if
done
less than that we can say that the
chances of that happening by random
chance is very low and it actually does
have something to do with the phenomenon
that they're looking at the authors also
looked at IG m and so here again if
we're looking at the median for each of
the data sets we see within the first
week you do see a slight increase of the
amount of antibodies produced from
survey pressure patients and the same is
true for those post two weeks of
symptoms onset once again this is a
small data set so we can only come up
with conclusions based on the sample
size that we have so what did authors
show so far so all of the patient
samples that they've tested so looking
at their serums and looking for
detectable antibodies a hundred percent
of them produce IgG antibodies about two
to three weeks after they started to
have symptoms IgM antibodies the amount
seems to decline after about three weeks
of having symptoms and there seems to be
a trend where patients with severe
symptoms are producing slightly higher
levels of IgM and IgG with significance
only seen in the first week post
infection with IgG antibody levels all
right so I'm gonna dive in a little bit
deeper on the second version of
antibodies so I mentioned cert
conversion just means being negative and
being able to detect either the IgM or
IgG in this case antibodies in a
particular patient so in order to combat
these questions we the scientist came up
with three different scenarios so the
first is what we call synchronous or
conversion and so what that means is
that you're able to detect both IgG and
IgM antibodies at the same time post
symptoms onset the next scenario is if a
patient produces IgM earlier than IgG
and this is kind of the model that
scientists use for other viral
infections where I GM is being detected
first followed by IgG antibodies a
couple days after they are able to
detect IgM and the third
conversion method is whether or not you
can detect IgG antibodies earlier than
you can detect IgM so here you can
detect IgG a few days later you can then
detect IgM so another poll which version
of sir conversion do you think is
occurring with patients who've been
infected with kovat 19 do you think it's
synchronous sir conversion do you think
it's i GM first and then IgG or do you
think it's i GG first followed by IgM
give you a couple seconds to answer so
we'll end the poll and so about 75% of
the audience thinks that IgM are
produced first and then IgG and then
about 20% thinks it's IgM and IgG being
produced or detected at the same time
now I'm not going to tell you to answer
I'm just going to show you the data
alright so in order for the author's to
look at dis sir conversion that's
happening a couple things that they
looked at so they have 63 patients and
they're able to have serum samples in
three day intervals now out of those 63
patients 96% of them were able to Sarah
convert antibodies so they were able to
detect either IgG IgM or both of these
antibodies but within that 63 patients
they were able to gather 27 patients
when they were hospitalized there we
initially seronegative
so what sir- means is that day they are
unable to detect the presence of IgG or
IgM antibodies and so they took this
sample and these samples of patients and
they looked at
when these patients are producing either
IgM or IgG all right so let's see what
the scientists find out so now we're
looking at individual datasets so each
dot again is looking at each individual
person producing a certain type of
antibodies
so let's Zone in on the x-axis so here
we're looking at the days after symptoms
onset and on the y-axis we're just
looking at the amount of either the IgG
or the IgM the red circles are IgG and
the blue triangles are IgM and so for 10
out of those 27 patients they're
actually seeing that they're able to
detect IgG before they're able to detect
IgM and the median days of Sarah
conversion where they can detect these
antibodies it's about two weeks or
thirteen days post symptoms onset and so
what does it look like is something like
this where you're seeing or you're being
able to detect IgG antibodies I'm in
comparison to IG M antibodies what
happens a short time after next they're
able to show that nine out of those
twenty seven patients actually produced
IgM and IgG antibodies at the same time
and so on the bottom the x-axis is the
same so you're seeing about six days
after symptoms onset you have patients
where you can detect the both of these
antibodies once against their a
conversion of both of these antibodies
occur on average about 13 days and
here's what that graph would look like
where you have the detectable levels of
IgM and IgG antibodies occurring at the
same time and then the patient's the
scientists had seven of those 27
patients actually produced or Sarah
converted IgM antibodies before they
produced IgG antibodies once again the
x-axis is the days after the patient
started to have symptoms where you're
able to detect IgM and antibodies and
later you can detect the IgG antibodies
with 13 days being that median day of
Sarah conversion so this graph would
look something like this where you're
producing IgM antibodies prior to IDG
antibodies so the answer to the question
is that it happens differently in
different patients I think this is
another reason to point out sometimes
how individual datasets actually is
super important when we're looking at
approaches for medicines I'm gonna move
on to the second goal and so I've shown
you within the sample set that the
scientists have when they're producing
antibodies and how these antibodies are
sir converted within these patients but
now that authors want to ask how cancer
allowed serology testing help identify
kovat 19:00 nicer ology testing is just
a fancy way to say that we're testing
for the presence of antibodies and so I
just fine-tune the graph based on the
data that I gave you remember this is
not really on 1 for all but this is just
a depiction of like the aggregate data
set and so on the bottom we have the
days post symptoms onset and so what you
see in the beginning what you have this
viral infection you can test with our t
PCR and you can see if you have levels
of the virus within that patient to show
that they're currently infective
equipment 19 now a lot of times patients
only good get tested if they're having
symptoms so you're feeling coming one
day the symptoms occur you're like oh
crap this might be coded 19 you get the
viral test they tell you that you're
positive but I just want to remind you
that there are patients who actually
never have symptoms right the only times
until recently where patients would get
tested is if they've been in too close
contact with patients who had confirmed
Kovan 19 so you have the asymptomatic
patients that may or may not get tested
now if the test is super accurate you'll
see that they tested positive for the
presence of the virus in their body by
using the RT PCR test but there are
cases where you can get false negative
results where the test can tell you that
you're negative for the virus but maybe
an actuality you've actually contracted
koban 19 and you're asymptomatic and you
did not know that
you had the presence of that virus in
your body
now that serological tests is where we
can look for IGM and igg and looking at
the presence of these antibodies can
allow scientists to figure out if a
patient have the presence of IgM meaning
that they have been infected with club
in 19 or the presence of IgG meaning
that there are currently infected or
they've recovered from kovat 19
infection and so what these authors did
is look at a number of patients who have
come into close contact with those who
have confirmed cope in 19 and so they
have 164 of those patients and they took
those patients and they use the RT PCR
test to look for the virus and out of
those 164 16 of them tested positive I'm
using the RT PCR test out of those 16 13
of them more symptomatic so they had
symptoms and three of them were
asymptomatic and all of them tested
positive for IgG or IgM or both now the
scientists also did rt-pcr tests on the
rest of the patients and these patients
had no symptoms and they also tested
negative by the RT PCR test now 30 days
after they tested negative they gave all
the patients and antibody tests and to
their surprise they were able to see
that 7 of them they were able to detect
IgG and/or IgM antibodies to SARS close
to and so what this is saying is that
not only did we have 10 patients out of
the one in 64 close contacts that were
asymptomatic but the rt-pcr missed about
4% of the patients who actually did
contract cope in 19 so what lessons can
we get from this and what story does
this tell and so it appears that
scientists are looking to initiate a way
that we can combine antibody testing we
rt-pcr test because it may be critical
to identify patients who currently have
koban 19 and those who recovered from
infection and so if we're able to
complement it to test ins this would
allow us to increase the accuracy for
infection and so they also showed that
all the patients that they looked at
that were infected with kovin 19
produced or Sarah converted detectable
levels of IgG now this idea antibody
like I mentioned before is the antibody
that scientists think may infer immunity
but we're still unsure as to how long
this immunity lasts and if you wanted to
learn more about if you can get
reinfected I would like if you can check
out Joe's talk who talked about a study
that scientists did in macaques where
they were unable to reinfect
these monkeys with stars close to but
also you want to bear in mind that this
may not necessarily translate to humans
and they also showed that patients
produce IgM and IgG antibodies that can
be detected at different time points
after they started having symptoms but
on average if we're looking at the
aggregate data it appears to be about
two weeks after you start having
symptoms to cope it 19 and so I think
this is great that the study is tamas
all of this but once again with every
scientific article in every experiment
there are some limitations and so Wanda
did not test for the presence of
neutralizing antibodies what are
neutralizing antibodies II asked and so
these antibodies basically have the
ability to bind that specific virus code
it so that it's unable to infect the
cells so it gets rid of the virus even
before it comes into contact with your
cells even though we're producing
antibodies the antibodies may also be
necessary for recruiting other cells or
other molecules to get rid of infection
but infection may already be taking
place a new paper just came out and by
our archives so this is a preprint it
came out of Rockefeller University my
employer and so what they're showing is
that the patients that they looked at so
these are all patients in New York City
this data said that I'm showing you
today are all patients from China and
from the data set that they're looking
at it appears that only a few people
who've been infected with SARS close to
are producing high amounts of
neutralizing antibodies but it doesn't
mean that we're not the others are not
producing any at all it just might be a
minor amount of antibodies that they're
unable to detect in the laboratory so
feel free to check out that paper also I
just want to pinpoint that the sample
size of the study is fairly small so we
only look at about 280 patients for a
lot of the data that I showed you
but even when we're looking at severe
versus critical patients they're only
about 20 that we classified as severe
and critical and so even though it
showed a trend with the aggregate data
we're still unsure as to how the
antibody correlates with the clinical
course of infection and also this does
not look at the changes in antibody
responses for a prolonged period of time
remember the scientists only had the
ability to test patients who were
hospitalized and so once they were able
to leave the hospital they were unable
to test them so even though we are
producing IgG antibodies and they also
showed other data where there seemed to
be like I usually antibodies are
plateauing we can't really say anything
for pass about 25 days post symptoms
onset because the authors did not look
into that